do you think there was in the history of
life on earth species that may be still
alive today
that are more intelligent than humans
and we just don't know
it's going to be made for dolphins like
if you look at their brains if you look
at the
way that they play if you look at the
way that they learn
uh you know i mean they don't have
possible thumbs and we do
so you know that probably made a big
difference it's terrifying to think that
like
not terrifying i don't know how to feel
about it that they're more intelligent
than us
it's like a hitchhiker's guide i know
but how do you define intelligence
basically like i was saying last time
you know stupid is a stupid does and
smart is a smart does so
yeah if the dolphins are basically super
smart
figure out the meaning of life and just
go around playing with water all day
which is probably the meaning of life
then we wouldn't know because all
they're doing is kicking water just like
sharks are and sharks are probably
pretty stupid
so so basically it's very difficult to
sort of
judge a species intelligence unless you
they kind of go out of their way to
demonstrate it
yeah and that's instructive for our
understanding of any kind of life form
you